[Applause]
hi lonnie
hi mister how are you
i'm doing fine how about you i mean it's
the morning i don't really like mornings
but
i'm happy to be alive i'm grateful
that's that
literally how old are you i'm 13 years
old
that's exactly where you're supposed to
be like
i hated mornings too i think until i was
30 in my late 30s actually and
you know you learn a lot along the way
and it sounds like lonnie that you
learned a lot from david working on this
film will you tell me about that
well first i want to say you think it
would be hard for someone who's not only
an actor and a director of a movie
especially on their first director debut
mr david
because of how many things they have to
control but
mr david never bumped a transition i
mean he made it look like a walk in the
park throughout the whole
entire set of the movie and honestly it
was such
it was such a pleasure to work with him
i feel so grateful
i have to say lonnie i was looking into
your anti-bullying campaign
fix your heart and i was wondering if
you would talk about it because
i am so swept away with it and i would
love to hear
you explain why you started this
sure um well fix your heart is an
anti-bullying campaign that i created
with my mom after being told online and
offline that i need to fix my gap that i
had in my teeth
and i said racist can fix this but can
you fix your heart though
so we created fixture our tv where i
bring on people to talk about their
experiences and hopefully change other
people's perspectives
to be kinder people and we created a
clothing line because i love fashion and
part of the proceeds goes back to fix
yard tv and other
inspiring charities that i believe um do
you mean this
because i'm holding it because i got a
box for you
oh yeah i got a box of of swag
and i want to wear it so proudly i
have to tell you i'm not kidding i i
i love the message of this so much and i
want to share it with my kids
and i just love your fix your heart tv
you interview people about being kind
um and david you know
is it would it be okay if you quickly
interviewed uh lonnie and i
both right now for fix your heart tv
would you be up for that yes
absolutely i've got some prepared
questions okay perfect
when you realize you've hurt someone by
your actions
how do you fix your heart well you know
the whole purpose
and the whole definition of fix your
heart is to have the accountability to
correct your own actions and be better
to others and mainly sometimes just
yourself and
i mean how do i fix my own heart have
the accountability to say sorry
100 i uh
i feel like that is probably where i
hold myself the most accountable
i wish i had half a quarter
one percent of the concern for myself
that i do for others
which is probably a good start and maybe
enough sometimes but if i ever do things
that i
think don't feel right
i i really hold myself accountable
lonnie would you like to extend the same
questions to david if you don't mind
oh a hundred percent let's go
well um now you have both
been in the business before the time of
social media unlike me
and social media has given canceling
people a
whole culture making mistakes are
inevitable though because we are human
of course so miss drew do you worry
about making a mistake
and being canceled
yeah um i never want to
say things or do things that hurts
anybody
um because it's the last thing on earth
i want to do
i don't want to affect other people
negatively david what do you think
gosh it's a really great question um
i mean first and foremost you know i do
try to live by
treat each other's as you would like to
be treated
um and so you know to have compassion to
have kindness
to have empathy um
is the way to lead to understand you
know and and
for me personally as a black person
especially
you know i know what
it feels like to be willfully
misunderstood mistreated
uh marginalized and so i absolutely
refuse to do that
to another person i think
love the definition of love is to put
others before yourself
and if you're doing that i think there's
a real chance that you won't
go hurting anyone certainly not
knowingly anyway
i love hearing that and you know
lonnie i want to thank you for coming on
this show
and allowing our show to
jump in into fix your heart tv with
david
because when i saw it and was pouring
through it i just fell in love with your
mission
thank you thank you for having 50 rtv on
your show it really means a lot to me
thank you and most importantly to speak
about your beautiful
um feature directorial debut
and this gorgeous story that you're
telling in the water man david o yellow
oh
and lonnie chavis thank you for bringing
the water man which is
in theaters right now to all of us and
asking the questions that you asked
thank you thanks for having us drew
thank you so much
thank you i appreciate it so much thank
you
[Music]
you